welcome everyone to the
thursday conference of the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology at
oregon health and science university um
we have this conference uh every
thursday and occasionally at other times
when it needs to be done then
and um we like to have a wide variety of
presentations
and we also um
even before the pandemic were uh
broadcasting them
and recording them and we continued to
to do that
uh obviously now in the pandemic we
are doing these um remotely
virtually so it gives me a great
pleasure today to
welcome dale sanders who
is someone that i've gotten to know
actually uh where
else over social media um and it turns
out we have a lot of um
common interests both in informatics and
beyond
um and um uh he and i have been chatting
over the last few months he he
is uh very passionate about clinical
data
as are many people in our department um
and um kicking around some ideas and he
wanted to kind of put those ideas
together
more formally and so i um
invited him to come speak to our
conference with the goal
that he gave us a presentation and we
will give him feedback
constructive but cordial as we always
are and um
he will um hopefully find it useful
to get our feedback and continue
these conversations on a larger scale um
so um dale um is uh currently
um an executive partner with ardon
equity um but uh has uh spent
um a lot of time in the last decade or
so working for the company health
catalyst which
many of you know about it's a data
analytics company
in the healthcare space he started out
as senior vice president for strategy
became chief technology officer and
stepped back from that role
uh last year now as a a senior advisor
uh he's also worked for the advisory
board company
um he's uh had experience in the
military he's uh he's he's
been in in many different places and i
could go on and on but i don't want to
take away time from his talk
um his uh formal education has a
bachelor's degree in chemistry and
biology from fort lewis college also did
some study at the u.s
air force institute of technology and um
again if dale you wish to add anything
else about your background you think
it'd be informative i'll let you at it
because i could
literally spend the whole hour
introducing you uh but i i think
probably most of us want to hear your
talk
so um i will turn it over to you as as
always
um um people can feel free to type
questions in the chat
when dale's done talking you can unmute
and
talk to him we do encourage people to
keep their video on
unless they're eating lunch which
happens at this hour including myself
but uh hopefully you'll be engaged with
the talk
so i will uh turn it over to him
thanks very much bill i appreciate you
um
sponsoring this venue for me this is a
topic i've been evangelizing for a while
and
this audience is the first one to see
sort of my current
thoughts about it and um i'm looking for
criticisms as much as i am compliments
and uh
some validation or invalidation of the
um of the assertions i have here
so let me share my screen
and we will dive in i'm assuming
everyone can see that
okay so as the
title uh was indicated during the invite
this is all about the evolution of the
ehr
and reducing clinician data entry burden
while improving the state of data that
we need in the industry
there are three parts to the discussion
today part one is
i want to share with you about why i
care about this
part two is the assertions and the
evidence that uh support those
assertions
and then part three is my thoughts about
how to approach solving the problems
described in those assertions
here's the usual disclosures and
affiliations and i try very hard to
never let
any of these influence what i believe to
be the honest truth
and bill mentioned some of those i'm a
board member for a company called health
tree
executive partner at art equity senior
advisor health catalyst i'm a limited
partner at foresight capital to invest
in
healthcare-related technology senior
advisor to
imo which you folks probably know and
i'm a senior advisor at the national
institute for civil discourse and common
sense american
um there'll be a poll at the conclusion
of the discussion today
and i'd like to for you to think about
this during the course of the discussion
on a scale of five i'd love to hear
whether you strongly
disagree or strongly agree with the
following
the burden of ehr data entry to satisfy
quality measures and reimbursement
models is contributing to physician
burnout
data quality that is complete valid and
current data
in ehrs meets the needs of patient
specific care
population health and clinical research
and finally the us needs a national
federally convened strategy to reduce
the ehr data entry burden on clinicians
while at the same time improving the
quality of ehr data that is collected
and shared
okay think about those and then i'll ask
for some formal data from all of you
at the end of the poll assuming that
lauren can get the uh
the poll working we're not quite sure
okay
so part one is you know why am i
advocating this and
what's why the heck is dale sanders
doing this as opposed to
someone like you know bill hirsch or
nicole weiskopf that have done research
and lots of publications in this
field um fundamentally
the first thing is i believe that our
digital understanding of patients is
poor
and i use this graphic to share that as
a metaphor this is my life on the left
and on the right is healthcare's digital
view of my life and we have to do a
better job as an industry and as
professionals
to round out the precision and the
granularity
of these views of patients and their
true lives
i would also say we can't achieve
precision medicine
without precision data the potential of
ai
and healthcare will never be realized if
we don't change the way we're using ehrs
and i borrowed gartner's hype cycle on
the right there
to show that we will stay
here in the trough of disillusionment if
we don't do something to improve
the depth and breadth of data and the
quality of data that we're collecting
about patients
i have a genuine sincere empathy for
doctors and nurses
we burden them with collection of data
that has questionable value to their
professional calling
then we strip them of their autonomy by
measuring their performance with that
same
questionable data and i would ask all of
you
all of us that are neither a physician
nor a nurse at this time
would you change your career to be in
their shoes at this time in history
and i don't think there are many of us
that would and so we have to change that
um and physician burnout clinician
burnout is a big
reason that i'm interested in solving
this problem around data entry in the
ehrs
my personality is just naturally
inherently fascinated with finding the
ground truth in any setting
my life motto is find the truth tell the
truth
and face the truth we are a long way
from an understanding of ground truth
about patients and their health so
inherently this is just a fascinating
topic for me to get to
that intersection between our beliefs
and truths and exposed knowledge
bill talked a little bit about my career
37 years so far hopefully that keeps
going for a while
and it's all been about data and optimal
decision making before healthcare i was
an air force officer specializing in
nuclear warfare command center
operations
at trw a big space defense contractor i
worked for nsa
in the nuclear threat reduction space
and at intel
i built their first data warehouse that
managed and helped them optimize their
supply chain and
fabrication processes i made the jump to
healthcare
landed at intermountain where i was
executive director of medical
informatics at lds hospital and the
largest region at lds i'm quietly very
proud
of that role it was i was the only
non-md non-phd to ever hold that
position
it was a big honor for me then i went on
to northwestern i went to the cayman
islands
went to health catalyst now at art and
equity where we invest in data and
software
companies so i've got a pretty good view
of what data and optimal decision making
is all about and
especially in healthcare for the last 20
or 25 years
and finally why do i care about this and
my wife
she's a mathematician statistician and a
data scientist in healthcare
and she's uh never far away from telling
me that your fancy schmancy data
warehouses are full of crappy data
and so there's full truth or half half
joking full truth to that comment that
she reminds me of
i want to acknowledge uh that mickey
tripathi and i were collaborating on
this slide deck
months ago uh very happy and pleased to
know that mickey is now leading onc
and so maybe in a position to further
the agenda that we're talking about here
today
uh sarah mcginty london who is at
centene a very large payer
the managed care space is now my
collaborative partner
it's super important i think that payers
be engaged in this messaging
and and in the changes are ahead because
economics drive a lot of
the reasons that we're collecting the
data that we are right now
so money talks and we need the insurance
companies to get on board with data
quality
and reducing physician burden
i want to emphasize too that it's not
the ehr's fault
right i've been around ehrs just like
all of you cerner
epic i mean the list is long could the
user interface of ehrs be better
sure of course but the bigger problem is
how we're using the ehr
and especially the data entry burden of
quality measures associated with billing
and reimbursement okay
part two my four assertions
number one we're burning out our
clinicians with data entry
the personal and professional burden of
data entry and ehrs is contributing to
physician burnout and job
dissatisfaction
and distracts from effective care
through the patient clinician
relationship that's assertion one
assertion number two we're using the
wrong data
the data that clinicians are required to
collect reflects too much emphasis on
reimbursement billing and defensive
medicine
and not enough emphasis on situational
awareness hypothesis generation
and intervention and outcomes assessment
said otherwise population health
precision medicine
clinical research should be
the driving factors behind the data that
we
choose to collect in an ehr we can
figure out
how to achieve billing and reimbursement
and satisfy
the lawyers in defensive medicine we can
figure that all out as a byproduct of
focusing our data strategies on
population health
precision medicine and clinical research
assertion number three we need to change
our quality measure strategy
quality measures of questionable
clinical value are a major contributor
to
the data entry burden our national
quality measures strategy must be
adjusted
to reduce the number and complexity of
process oriented quality measures
and shift to emphasize the reduction of
low value care
so think about that because i spent a
lot of time on
shifting the emphasis from process or
inequality measures
to the avoidance of low value care
i'm going to spend a lot of time
supporting that assertion
number four we must standardize our data
obviously
kovid put a spotlight on this problem
but we already knew
all about it right the past national
emphasis
on exchanging messages between ehrs must
now be shifted to improving the quality
and the standardization of data that's
being exchanged
we must achieve comprehensive and
persistent use of link
rxnorm and snomed in orders and results
then follow up with standardized patient
cohorts and value sets
around those patient types that's the
beginning of the data standardization
journey
uh to be clear i don't care who leads
this change or how i'm just trying to
raise awareness
planting seeds of thought in hopes they
grow
all right now let's go into the
supporting evidence behind these
assertions
we're burning out our clinicians with
data entry so we need to stop this
vicious feedback loop of clinician data
entry burden
which feeds the dehumanizing measurement
of those same clinicians and that's the
circle in the upper right
data entry burden we then measure them
with that questionable
data and it further strips them in their
sense of mission and purpose
so as indicated in several studies
ehrs are contributing to burnout and
we're seeing the highest suicide rate of
any profession
among physicians greater than 50 burnout
in all specialties
for heaven's sakes we have to change
this right if for no other reason the
golden rule
and sense of empathy for what we're
doing to physicians and nurses
or some of the most mission driven
people in the world
we have to do better another article
that came out in the lancet in september
2019
the empathy and the age of electronic
medical record from danielle orfory at
nyu
her quote was pretty powerful there is
at least one upside to this mess
however the aggressiveness of the emr's
incursion into the doctor-patient
relationship
has forced us to declare our loyalties
are we taking care of patients
or are we taking care of the emr
the good news is at a national level
thanks to those who contributed the 21st
century's cure
act there's a focus now there's a
requirement at the federal level
to reduce the effort and time required
to record information in ehrs
regulatory reporting and improve the
functionality and
intuitiveness of ehrs and there are four
work groups currently working on this
and i'm
keeping my fingers crossed that mickey
being the great
professional person that he is will push
this agenda forward
very aggressively
assertion number two we're using the
wrong data
we need to shift our strategy to the
data of population health
patient specific care and clinical
research
bill credit to you for your long history
in raising the awareness of this problem
this is a great paper
describing how the data that we're
collecting in ehrs
is a questionable value and has some
significant caveats
related to comparative effectiveness
research
so our awareness of this problem has
been around for a long time thanks to
people like bill
and nicole weiss now it's time for
us to actually do something about it
this is a great diagram from bill's
paper
describing the relationship between
central tenets of biomedical informatics
and data centric caveats
pertaining to the design and the conduct
of comparative
research and what i would say is it's
like navigating with
gps that's only accurate to within 20
miles
patients deserve better precision in the
data that we're using
to make decisions about their lives this
is a great framework
so as we go forward with solving these
problems we have all of these great
thinkers that are already put a lot of
time
and intellectual capacity into
describing the problem
now we have a place to start
solving the problem okay thanks to these
papers
this is a great paper that came out in
july of 2019 from toronto microsoft
johns hopkins etcetera
opportunities of machine learning for
health care it's a great paper if you
haven't read it i highly recommend it's
super insightful
diseases in ehrs are poorly labeled
conditions can encompass multiple
underlying endotypes
and healthy individuals are
underrepresented
this article serves as a primer to
illuminate these challenges and
highlights opportunities for members of
the machine learning community
to contribute to healthcare back to my
previous comment we will never
realize the full potential of ai and
machine learning
that other industries are leveraging if
we don't do something to improve
the breadth and depth and quality of the
data
that we are collecting in healthcare and
especially in ehrs
i would also point out that the the text
that we're collecting in clinical notes
is questionable quality
some of that is contributed by
the cut and paste and the templates
that are enabled by ehrs
but also a lot of is frankly just
because fee for service medicine drives
volumes over quality
and when you're a clinician it's a lot
easier to cut and paste and move on to
the next patient
than it is to give you know really
thoughtful
content to your progress notes and
clinical notes
in a typical note according to this
jam article 18 of the text was manually
entered
46 percent was copied and 36 imported so
that's not precisely describing
patients and this is actually something
that physicians could take care of on
their own right now
if we could back off on feast for
service volume based medicine that is
i do believe there's lots of opportunity
for us to improve
the standards and the principles around
clinical notes there's a lot of
variation
a lot of variation in clinical notes
across the industry
another interesting point in this jma
article was that
the documentation that's entered in an
ehr
does not equal the observed physician
behavior so this is a fascinating study
that revealed 61 percent of the time
ehr data did not reflect reality in the
review system
so they had an observer in the exam room
looking at the interaction between the
patient and the physician
then that observer compared what they
saw in the interaction with what was
entered in the ehr
and there was a significant gap between
what was recorded in the hr
and what the observer noted in the
interaction
this is a great paper from your
colleagues
your colleague nicole weiskopf and it's
the headline there the paper describes
it well
there's a significant bias in ehr data
towards
sick patients significant bias
so machine learning and ai are going to
incorporate that bias
and this is a strong quote from the
paper these results
should serve as a word of caution to
researchers
wishing to use ehr data for research
investigators
wishing to reuse eh dart data must be
aware that blind sampling of complete
records
within an ehr database may skew the
sample population towards
sicker patients this is just a summary
of the amount of data by asa class
a physic a physical status
classification of the patient
for labs and medications but this is a
very deep informative paper
i highly recommend everyone spend time
on this paper if you're interested in
the topic
so i would say given that we are only
really collecting
most of our data on sick patients what
if the only time the airline gas and oil
industry collected data
about the health of their assets after a
failure we have to change our mindset to
collecting data on
all patients assertion number three
we need to change our quality measure
strategy which will reduce the data
entry burden and return professional
autonomy and purpose to clinicians
this was a great paper uh that came out
from some of the luminaries some of the
the you know 20 30-year advocates of
quality measures in the industry came
out
about a year ago and it was essentially
a summary of what have we learned about
quality measures in the industry over
this many years
many decades precipitated by the iom
study in the 90s
and here a couple of quotes from the
paper and by the way the paper
essentially says we're not doing well
with quality measures
so this quote what is primarily missing
is not progress in measurement
but prior progress in results
reading between the lines we're over
measuring and we're not seeing results
the second quote therefore the hope
reflected in the founding of nqf
the developing certifying and using
sound metrics of the quality of health
care would drive fundamental improvement
remains largely unrequited so we really
have to step back
friends now is the time to step back and
really real
rethink our quality measure strategy it
is not
working and it's creating an enormous
burden on clinicians and administrative
burden on the system
my favorite quote from this paper was
this one
the old saw says weighing a pig does not
make it fatter
inventing the thermometer does not
change the temperature
and assessing the quality of care does
not change the care
so what i am suggesting is that we shift
and by the way you also have to remember
that
my the beginning of my healthcare career
started at intermountain which was
probably the pioneer
in really embracing quality measures
brent james was an enormously
influential person on my career in my
thinking
so i'm all about measuring i'm all about
improving
but what we're doing with most of our
measures is really about evidence-based
care
and processes of care we're asking docs
do more of this which leads to over
diagnosis
over treatment and it equates to more
data entry to prove
they did what i'm suggesting
is that we shift to an easier topic with
enormous value financially
and in terms of health to patients
and we shift to low value care where
we're asking docs do
less of this which equates to less data
entry
because the absence of data about an
order or procedure means they didn't do
it
so not only are we shifting to more
understandable quality measures in low
value
care but we're also constant
consequently removing a data entry
burden from clinicians
as a result
and i think we all know that and there's
plenty of evidence to suggest that a lot
of our
quality measures are clinically invalid
this was a great paper
led by catherine mclean and others that
looked at 271 measures in the quality
payment program
86 of those were related to general
internal medicine so
catherine team put together a panel to
review those 86
measures and they found that 37
were completely invalid clinically and
20 8
were of questionable validity but yet
we're still asking
clinicians to collect data about those
and then we're measuring by those
and i can't think of anything that would
be more disheartening
if i were a clinician caught in that
trap
i would also suggest that that a lot of
our emphasis on quality measures comes
from a perspective of evidence-based
standards of care where we are telling
physicians what they should do
but the truth is by any number of
studies
a significant portion of evidence-based
standards
are later reversed in fact this paper
would suggest that 46
of standards of care were reversed
so the debate about what constitutes
evidence-based care is constant and
volatile we're still
learning about healthcare in the human
body but we're getting much better
about understanding what we shouldn't do
as opposed to what we should do
here's another study 396 medical
reversals
again from sponsored by a lot of the
brilliant folks at oregon
health sciences university okay
another study about low value care in
the military health system which was an
interesting study because
it there are two economic models in the
military health system one is direct
care where
um you know there shouldn't be any
economic incentives for
for over treatment
and also purchase care so in both
economic
models there was too much care
low value care especially
another study from rand
university of michigan also shows how
the reduction of low value care equates
to significant cost savings
so 44 low value care services were
studied
586 million dollars in unnecessary
direct costs
over five and a half million
beneficiaries
another study from deloitte about how
much we can save in the u.s
210 billion dollars a year in direct
unnecessary costs per year
from low value care
the cms has done a pretty good job
defining low value care it's a
relatively small
discussion it's a relatively small
number of things to debate
is what i would argue as opposed to the
discussion about evidence
based care i think
low value care provides a highly
valuable
lower data entry approach to data
collection in ehrs
yet another article from out of the
folks at university
of washington about the use of best
practice alerts
in an ehr to reduce
low value high cost medication
prescriptions significant savings
so lots of evidence to move our quality
measures strategy
towards low value care assertion number
four is we must standardize our data
and if accountants and retailers can do
it we can do it
so generally accepted accounting
principles and upc barcodes
are really all about data governance
standard data collection
reporting and analytics
our entire financial industry
in the us is based around
generally accepted accounting principles
we put a lot of faith and trust that
everyone is
looking at data collecting data and
reporting data in a very trustworthy way
those standards in the financial
industry and in the retail industry are
have
innumerable downstream business and
consumer benefits
we can easily borrow from these lessons
learned in healthcare and move forward
with
a better approach to our data
this is an example of
the data quality at a national level
a simple query against health catalyst
touchstone national data warehouse
recently
across 80 million patients contains
granular data from essentially every
ehr vendor in the u.s it was an analysis
of covid related lab results from a
subset of that 80 million
and we found that of six billion lab
results
only six percent of those were
harmonized like
and drilling further in a field that
should have had a cardinality of
four it had a cardinality of over 750
so not only is it not well harmonized to
a standard vocabulary
but there is enormous variability in
what should be a low cardinality field
this was another
report that came out from the evidence
accelerator
task force in which we mashed
two data sets together essentially to
see what kind of overlap we had
so 629 000 patients
where diagnosis in ehrs and diagnosis
and claims were compared
and there were out of that 629 000 only
45
000 had a similar diagnosis in both sets
so there's something fundamentally wrong
with what we're doing here friends
a great paper from nicole weiskopf again
uh amazing amount of work that she's
done and studied in this
in this area this paper describes a
great framework
for assessing the data
in ehrs for re reuse so we have the
framework we have
all of the thought that's gone into this
now it's a matter of implementing it at
a national level
this is a great summary of that a 3x3
matrix i won't go into the details here
but
comparing and describing in a very
simple understandable way what
constitutes
data quality in an ehr again we have a
framework here
we have a really good framework for
getting started on improving data
quality across the country
okay so part three what can we do
here are a few ideas but this is where i
would really appreciate a lot of
criticism and feedback to see whether
what i'm saying here is
of any validity really right i don't
want to waste time on
concepts that are not valid and good for
the country
so i would suggest that there's three
parts to the data quality strategy
there's data quality at the front end
there's data quality at the middle
and there's data quality in the back end
so on the front end
of course it's enforcing and governing
standards and principles on the front
end of data collection
starting from the question what data do
we need to support
population health specific patient care
precision medicine
and clinical research
following lessons learned from gap
accounting principles
apply that to ehrs including clinical
notes
in the middle we have to figure out how
we're reconciling patient identity is
fundamentally important i'll talk a
little bit more about that later
and then on the back end we need tools
to harmonize data that slip
through the front end data quality check
you know who do we care about we need
standard definitions for patient types
and subtypes
registries what do we care about
as it relates to those patients we need
standardized value sets for patient
types and subtypes
it took us months at a national level
to come up with a non-volatile
definition
of a covit patient and it took us even
longer to come up with
answers to what do we care about
relative to those coveted patients
we need to turn those definitions around
faster in the industry
and then make them broadly available for
reuse
a couple of thoughts on patient
identifiers i would suggest we should
follow lessons learned from
the management of internet domain names
and retail upc codes
that is create centralized governance
but
commercialized implementation of
national patient identifiers
doesn't have to be mandated for everyone
in the country
but i think it makes absolute sense to
man
to require a mandatory patient id unique
patient id for medicare medicaid
and dod va patients and they make it
voluntary for other patients
with an insurance premium and or tax
dividend for participating in having a
unique id
i have a feeling that there's a vast
majority of
the us population who would agree with
this if they knew how important it was
there will always be folks who are
concerned and we should respect
their concerns about government identity
management
but i believe we could create a
framework like this and
we could get 70 to 80 percent of the
population to participate
i believe we need generally accepted
principles for clinical notes you know
we see
significant variation i funded nlp and
text analysis i've been in the details
of clinical notes for my 25 years in the
industry there's significant variation
in clinical notes for the same patient
scenarios
principles are taught in med schools and
the principles are somewhat outdated
but in the field it's the wild wild west
ehrs need to support better structure
and content
we need to create economic incentives to
drive data quality so where economic
incentives support attention to data
quality such as in the quality measures
we have
ehr data quality is reasonably high
around quality measures
you know how i feel about quality
measures that's a different topic
but we've created economic incentives
around quality measures so therefore the
data that we collect in ehrs is
is pretty high in that regard but we
need new economic
frameworks to make ehr data useful for a
broader set of purposes beyond billing
and reimbursement
and we need a concentrated public
private collaborative to address this
situation
so now we need to start looking around
and say who's willing to pay for better
data
what types of economic levers can we
pull and are available
and who has them who has money that's
willing to pay for improvements to each
our data
clinical outcomes and clinical trials
we should look at value-based care
arrangements that incentivize
data beyond the quality measures that we
have now
there are targeted incentives through
mips and other commercial incentives
that should
pay for data quality the public health
requirements at cdc in the states
they suffer because of the poor data
quality
we're wasting money because they don't
have the good data they need
certainly the fda and the pharmaceutical
and life sciences
world benefits financially from better
data quality
grants at nih cms conditions of
participation
commercial payers there's plenty of
players in the economic world who should
have an interest
in incentivizing a new ehr
data strategy for the country
so in closing i would love if lauren if
you can pop up the poll friend i would
love
if we can't get the poll going then
maybe we have a conversation
um offline but i would love for
everyone's reflection on
those questions
and i also want feedback on whether you
know are my assertions accurate or
not are they defendable or not is this
an issue or not
because as i mentioned you're this is
the first audience in which i plan on
evangelizing these concepts
and if they're invalid i certainly don't
want to waste
other people's time and if they are
valid i'd like to strengthen the
assertions and the arguments as
as much as i possibly can thank you
yes lauren ah there we go okay ah there
it is
ah there it is
give me data give me data
this is a whole new process
so i assume one is low and five is high
yes or is it the other way around yeah
thanks
do i get to vote do i get to vote
probably if it's offering it to you
you know what while people are voting
there are some comments in the
chat box um that you know you could
scroll down and address if you'd like
yes for sure yeah that's for sure okay
some interesting pieces
interesting end up being a little
confused by that but i'll do
my best um
let's see here i'm reading
uh from john lee hi john
any thoughts on drinking better data
doesn't create cpts at least not true
yeah i i think we have to change
um and move towards value-based care
right friend
and get away from volume of care which
is why it's super important for cms
and the commercial payers to get on
board
with this and flex their economic
incentives to move us towards
value-based care that said
you know i don't think i still think we
can make
progress on the fundamental thesis of
improving data quality and reducing
clinician burden
even if we stayed in a fee-for-service
model
especially if we shifted to a focus on
low value care
as opposed to the ad nauseam
emphasis that we have on
processes of care
while the voting is going on i'm just
curious if i can ask a question
or are you
sure sure what's the incentive
what's the incentive for insurance
companies
to i mean they use the medical record as
a way of denying
care in many cases what's the insurance
what's the
incentive for them to make these changes
yeah i think that's a great question
friend i mean the the cynic in me
would say there is no incentive right
and and we've seen that for years
the insurance companies keep passing on
premium increases right
and uh so quality of care i would argue
to
the cynical side of me that insurance
company doesn't matter much
on the other hand i do think there is
momentum
among the insurance carriers towards a
different view
of that world we cannot keep consuming
the economy of the country
with premium increases um
that's one reason that sarah is a
welcome partner for me to carry this
message forward because i think the
insurance companies have to play an
active role in this
and by the way i also think we have to
bring on board the employers
who are largely footing the bill for
these um
these premium increases
in terms of insurance transformation
so what we what we see a lot is when you
is an increased documentation burden
like say for example the sep 1 um sepsis
requirements that emergency providers
have to do i mean what i've seen is
hospitals will just hire a full-time
uh person just to to go over all of the
documentation
go back and have clinicians remedy
deficiencies
so i mean they're still you know
cms uses that measure to deny payment
but in response you know hospitals are
just hiring
fleets of you know essentially
clinicians to go and make sure they do
get paid so
so overall you know i don't know how
much money cms is really saving
um they're just increasing the burden of
cost to the
health care system as a whole so i mean
eventually that that seems like that's
not going to help insurance companies
when
to caught you know everything is just
more and more expensive if they can pass
everything on to you know individuals
maybe but if they can't they're gonna
lose out
yeah i totally agree eric and i mean i
think that's a good example of
not just the emotional burden but the
administrative burden that these data
collection
requirements are putting on the system
um
which again i i believe i think the
the federal government is in a great
place to convene
uh the insurance companies to
participate in this because it's
it's killing the industry and it's
killing clinicians
and it's you know eating away at uh
at uh the economy
there there's also a comment in the chat
that i i would make too from
um dodge and um about um
her comment is avoidance of low value
care is certainly a noble goal but
can you comment on the us cultural
acceptability of restricting these
practices which
is something i think about because
oftentimes um
one one person's um unnecessary care
is another part of the health care
system's revenue stream
and um and and sometimes it gets caught
up in politics and so forth so um
you know how how do we um how do we
drive home
the uh which i and i completely agree
with you know aiming to
get low value care out of the system um
how do we make that happen
you know without some of the pushback
we're likely to get
yeah yeah great point
um i can remember years ago doing some
consulting for one of the largest ibm's
and i suggested that we reduce some of
these that they
immediately took it to the bottom line
of the revenue and said we can't it was
lab lab test um
i would say that money talks so i think
we can
create incentives and shared risk
incentives where the reduction of low
value care
um gives an incentive back to the
organization for those reductions right
it's sort of the invoice of what we're
doing
with the margins on bundle tournaments
for example
where um the cost savings associated
with the reduction of low value care
has a dividend back to the providers
right
in the pursuit of that pursuit but yeah
so dale the the conversation about low
value care
is is uh um part and parcel of your
data uh issues or is there the data
arguments that you're making because
um how do you define more value and if
it's much easier to define a successful
colonoscopy
or an arthroscopy with a cpt code and
get paid for it
um but then how do you then what is the
definition
of low value care and then it gets
into a very messy conundrum of
well uh if you define it that way
um now let's see let's say let's use
redundant actually an excellent use case
is actually the um
the uh struggle that we're having
with um the
appropriate use criteria in radiology um
the the workflows that are foisted upon
providers to document whether
a particular advanced imaging study
is is really really cumbersome
and from my perspective has been a
complete failure
given the current construct of what we
have available and
has uh added a huge amount of
documentation burden on the
the ordering providers um
and at the same time the the people who
are benefiting from all this uh extra
imaging
is a radiologist a ct manufacturer
there's an entire ecosystem of people
whose
uh um profit is the system's waste
so that you know all of that contributes
to a lot of the inertia that you're
you're
so eloquently describing
yeah i agree john and i i do recognize
that being a weakness of my low value
care argument
is that um there are times when
the low value care is actually
appropriate care right
and so you get into pre-authorization
and justification and things like that
i would say it's a lesser of evils
than the current approach that we have
to measuring processes of care
i think it's a lesser of evils i don't
necessarily think it's perfect but i
just think it's
simpler for one thing you know the the
definitions of low value care are
actually pretty manageable in terms of
their number
and complexity it's pretty easy for
um for us to identify what gee we
shouldn't be doing this
um in general so i think it's an easier
argument
and again kind of a lesser of evils but
i'm certainly open to other thoughts
just to be clear i i agree with you i'm
not trying to hurt
i'm just saying it's uh talking about
the
even though that it's relatively easy um
to uh uh define
high or low value care it's far easier
to do this colonoscopy flip the cpt code
and then
and get paid from that that's a good
point yeah really good point
back to dodging's comment cultural
acceptance of the concept
there's a lot of other comments here
bill do you want to moderate some of the
comments your friend
yeah there's some comments there which
is something of interest to me as well
um about you know ways of um
um uh extracting good data out of the
text
because um you know as as i've noted and
others as well um you know clinicians
want to read and write the story
um but the story oftentimes is um
challenging to get good unambiguous
data out of um and so a couple
um commenters have commented about the
use of machine learning ai
kinds of techniques for extracting
data out of the narrative
could you comment on on the use of the
narrative and ways that we might
process it to help us get good data
because that that's also the easiest way
for
clinicians to enter data is just to tell
the story right
so yeah i would love to do that actually
and now i'm going to lean on my nsa
background
which was all about text data there were
there was
some discrete metadata that we would
look at but most of the time
it was either text or translated
conversations that we're trying to make
sense of and
and i would say that we've and i funded
this kind of research so i'm at fault
with
what i'm about to describe i think we've
been trying to pull
discrete data elements out of clinical
notes for far
too long and it's a very difficult
problem to solve
not to say we should stop doing it but
we need to spend a little bit more time
on just pattern recognition of topics in
text
as opposed to pulling discrete topics
out so let me describe how the nsa works
for example
you present the output of
what for the most part it was neural
nets you present the output of pattern
recognition in text to an intelligence
analyst
that intelligence analyst looks at the
patterns that are emerging in text
and they present their human
interpretation of those patterns back to
decision makers
okay um
what we as opposed to trying to pull out
then i you know i literally did this
like
pulling out whether or not a terrorist
was specifically
going to attack at a point
using these means that kind of discrete
knowledge in text is
super super hard to pull out and it's
even more complicated given
the medical language that we deal with
right it's it's one thing to do that
with translated normal day-to-day
language and text but you know medical
vocabulary is a completely different
world
so i would advocate all of us as
informatics professionals we need to
start putting more emphasis
on pattern recognition in text around
topics
that then we expose to what i've been
calling a digitization
the modern version of a medical
informaticist expose that to a
digitization who then presents that back
to decision makers
and it could be that we present it back
in a meaningful way to
to clinicians but i actually think
there's a role for
these digitizations to serve as the
intermediary data person between the
clinician and the patient for
interpretation
um so that's one thought the other
thought is and this is based on
some work that we did at northwestern um
when i landed at northwestern we were in
the early stages of deploying both epic
and cerner and i watched the utilization
of clinical notes evolved
in that deployment and i saw a great
variation
some clinicians wanted to know this long
some clinicians wanted to know this long
even though the patient scenario was
essentially the same
so uh i worked with david leibovitz
dear friend uh gary martin
others at northwestern we just said hey
you know
let's just put out a one-page general
guidelines about how to get the most out
of your ehr we restricted it to one page
you could call it the first version of
meaningful use
it was it was one page just in general
this is in principle how you should use
an ehr
this is back in 2005 by the way so you
know 16 years ago
and we got general consensus from the
clinicians to converge on principles
around clinical notes that everyone
agreed with
in terms of breadth content um
brevity that kind of thing so it was
super successful for us
the interesting thing was it fed better
data into our nlp
experiments so i
would love to see a more national effort
on the part of
physicians and nurses to do a better job
around
guidelines in clinical notes because
there's too much
in my opinion there's way too much
variability in what we're typing into
ehrs right now
oh and john asked what john is which i i
still have that one
and they said there's a sad story
actually
david blumenthal and john glaser got
their hands on that document
and that was the seed that started
meaningfully
and i we all we all know what means good
um i'm just looking uh scrolling up and
down the list and i'll keep a copy of
this and
uh send it around um dana womack
another one of our faculty asking about
um
some of the things that are basic
aspects of care
um that may have lower urgency for for
example oral care
um to prevent hospital acquired
pneumonia i i wouldn't actually
necessarily think of that as low value
care but but it may be lower urgency
care
and may get lost in the shuffle and you
know some of those things can be really
important so if i'm misquoting you dana
speak up but um i i think this is an
issue that that sometimes we kind of
lose track
of the um um
you know the things that are truly
important they may not
seem big and you know and we're trying
to get rid of things that are
expensive and so forth that we lose
sight of some of the simpler things
i have a question question never mind go
ahead
it was also a little related to the
nomenclature too because if you think of
low value and people interpret that as
low cost you know and some of these
things that are discounted
in nursing already and relegated to aids
and gaps
when things get too busy it's like we
want to be careful not to
um discount those because they are very
important
yeah there's very there's actually very
high value low cost carriers they're
back to oral exams and things yeah
that's an interesting thought maybe we
need a list of low cost high value carry
that's an interesting thought
yeah and and actually a lot of the low
value
care is it can be high cost i mean uh
you know tests that we don't need that
expose
people to you know radiation or other
kinds of harms
um so i i don't i don't think of
um those sort of simple things as
necessarily low value
so there are a few a few more comments
in the chat box
i guess we're running up against the
hour here
um lauren did we ever get um the results
of the poll
or um
did that um
let me
[Music]
uh extract that so that i can spend some
time thinking about afterwards that
would be
super helpful
yeah we'll um we'll we'll capture
everything
so i i think we are uh just about at the
hour
this has been a great conversation and
it's obviously something that requires a
lot more than one hour
to um talk about so um i hope this is
only a beginning
and um you know i hope we can continue
to have this dialogue in the appropriate
forum
and um as this uh topic uh
percolates itself up into the uh
national conversation um
we'll see what happens so um i want to
um
thank dale for sharing his thoughts
with us um and everyone else for
joining the conversation and
participating
and um we'll hopefully find a way to
uh continue to keep this conversation
going
so uh have a great day everyone may
thank everybody